hey guys we've been hearing a lot about  this game called five nights at freddy's  so we grabbed it and it right off the  steam and we're just gonna go ahead and  check it out wait wasn't there something  here before Oh oh my god what's that oh  god oh no way that's it that's totally  something that's bear town I'm a bear  country I only have this much battery  scared myself I only have a lute oh I  only have eliminated a battery and also  celebrate oh okay I think helpings in a  pan I got it stand there but dawn thanks  how long is he out there  for god sakes bunny I can just lurking  around go away it sounds like when I  turn on the light oh my god bunny  [Music]  go away duck I don't want to eat I'm  hungry  [Music]